what up y'all
welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel it's morning coffee
thoughts
i've been doing a lot of these lately
i'd be lonely
okay okay
um before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos today
i'm about to go to the gym but i'm
drinking my coffee before i go
so
today i'm talking about loneliness
i think at some level most people are
lonely and don't feel understood
me but it's interesting because i also
think
that there's so many people out there
you would think like
and we're so much more connected than
ever right like you can watch someone
online you can like talk to someone but
we're lonelier than ever
and i asked my dad because again lately
this is something i've been struggling
with because
i've been working a lot
and
trying to build this channel and that's
something i'm really passionate about
and excited for
but
it comes at a cost everything comes at a
cost and one of the costs is that
i don't relate to a lot of people my age
um i don't i miss out on a lot of like
social stuff
and
you know not drinking like leave leaves
you alone sometimes okay
i'm actually i'm trying to go to church
this week so i can
yeah um anyways
[Music]
my dad just said like find something to
do
because my dad i don't think he gets it
as much because he's a dude and dudes
are just like
more capable of that than women in my
opinion
and that's what he tells me and it
really helps you to be honest um
like if i'm ever feeling like
oh wow i'm just like by myself
i just find something to do and get done
because there is always
always always always something to get
done
so
that's what happens when i get lonely
i'm just like okay well what can i get
done and it usually helps to be honest
because there's always something to get
done around your apartment or
like projects with work or whatever
another thing i've noticed
is that
i think social media
makes us be a little bit more lonely
because we rely on it for social
interaction and we feel like we have
more social interactions than we do so
one thing my dad always tells me dad is
the wisest guy i know okay um he always
tells me that
you really don't deal with that many
people and i think social media gives us
like a false sense of like dealing with
people
um like my last boyfriend and i
when i was dating him i unfollowed
everyone only followed him i just like
kind of it was just like one of those
things you do when you're in a
relationship i don't know like that's
not normal i just did it
because i thought it'd be funny i don't
know but a lot of people unfollowed me
because um
like i was friends with them or whatever
and they unfollowed me and it's
interesting because as soon as i like
stopped seeing their content and stuff
and when i did re-follow people like i
forgot to follow them back i realized
how little you really even talked to
them like i had a roommate i lived with
a couple years ago i haven't talked to
her in like two three years i would
still get lunch with her she's chill um
but
like you really don't deal with that
many people outside of your immediate
family and a couple close friends
actually
you might see their content you might
watch their posts on instagram on
facebook whatever and so we have this
feeling like like all these people's
opinions matter
and they don't like the only people's
opinions that matter are like your close
friends and your close family and that's
what my dad like
always drives home to me when
like i lost i told you guys i lost a
friend this year um
over my content
and he just said look at in life like
friends they come and go that's part of
life um
like the only this is why people stay
close to their family like this is why
it's important to stay close to your
family
and i think when i was younger there was
like a part of me that wanted
to get away because
you know you're just like a kid i'm like
oh get me out of this town right it's
like boring or whatever but the older i
get the more i realize like
like friends come and go but your
family's the ones that stays
and i really like my parents are getting
they're like in their 50s so they're
still young you know
but
um
i don't know i really appreciate like
the time i have with them
and i
i put it
and
i think it's really important to
stay close and like value the opinions
of your family rather than social media
so that's my morning coffee thoughts i'm
gonna go get this workout in okay guys
look it look it i'm getting jacked i'm
good you wait you wait for the summer
this summer you're not even gonna be
ready for me i'm gonna be skinny i wanna
be skinny for the first time since i was
like 18. so
you wait for it
don't forget to subscribe i'll talk to
you guys later